[Aplausos]
corrupto y mentiroso fueron los
adjetivos que usó Donald Trump para
referirse a la administración de Joe
biden en un acto de campaña desde su
club de golf en bethminster Nueva Jersey
el republicano volvió a asegurar que
todas las imputaciones en su contra son
a falsas yo soy el que sigue la ley Yo
soy el único
es Joe biden y su correcto departamento
de injusticia ellos son los que creen
que está por encima de la ley nunca
antes ha habido dos estándares de
justicia en el país
tildó de asalto el registro del FBI de
su casa de mar al lago en agosto de 2022
y a la pregunta de por Qué guardaba
documentos clasificados en su residencia
respondió que todo eran objetos
personales como fotografías o camisetas
pero las pruebas no indican lo mismo
según el departamento de Justicia los
documentos contenían información sobre
defensa y programas nucleares entre
otros no obstante el multimillonario
siguió con su estrategia asegurar a
persecución política en su contra y
culpar a los demócratas de hacer lo
mismo o incluso peor en su discurso
señaló directamente a Joe biden Bill
Clinton o hillary Clinton y también
aprovechó para amenazar al actual
presidente y a toda su familia
nombraré a un fiscal real para que
persiga al presidente más corrupto en la
historia de los Estados Unidos de
América Joe biden y a toda la familia
criminal biden
ahora se espera que la defensa de Trump
se ampare en la presidencial Records
aunque los expertos aseguran que esta no
permite retener documentos clasificados
al concluir la presidencia